[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
tim legler
had uh business shooting threes and legs
joins us now
what advice would you give these
shooters now or maybe the coaches now
these kids who are coming up in grade
school in high school
that all think that's how you get to the
next level uh by being a three-point
shooter
yeah dan that's that's a big challenge
because you're right i mean this is what
the nba
looks like now i think for me and i was
a three-point shooter that's how i made
my living
it's a little monotonous for me to watch
basketball now because
it seems like that's the intent of every
possession
to get a three-point shot and it was
used a lot differently obviously when i
played this different era the problem is
this is actually
filtered all the way down to the youth
level
certainly aau level go watch an aau
tournament one weekend and sit there
and you know watch six eight games on
the court in front of you pull up a
chair
and just take a look at what's going on
you're 100 right
there's a lot of guys taking that shot
because they've been empowered to do it
because
people are telling everybody the
analytics say that's the way to play
basketball now and there's too many guys
to me that have the ultimate green light
that don't deserve it that's that's what
i see when i watch basketball now
but i was wondering about this with
magic johnson magic couldn't shoot
when he first came out of michigan state
i mean he could run an offense
he was great wonderful passer i wonder
how the nba would treat him
if he was just coming out and he
couldn't shoot the three
or you know there's probably you know
tens 20 30 players that you can think of
that how would we
view them now if they were coming out
jason kidd jason kidd couldn't shoot
he became a good three-point shooter but
how do you think
basketball would have treated you know
legend hall of famers like that
yeah it's interesting well you're
talking about guys now at the very top
of the food chain right so you're
talking about magic
the most unique weapon in the history of
the game at that position
uh six nine powerful playing downhill
yeah you know no three-point shot but i
think people would look at him
as a weapon that you can use to set up
three-point shooters if he was coming
into the league now
because when you combine you know his
ability to rebound at that position
his ability to guard bigger guys because
the league now
is set up that way that you want a four
or five man that can switch out and
guard guards
that's what he would be yeah but ben
simmons is not like that
but ben simmons legs but ben simmons is
a great defender he can get to the hoop
he's a good
passer he just can't shoot deep and
you know we go how can he be an all-star
so
it's a very valid point as particularly
when you look at ben simmons because
you look at him and people are still and
i'm in the philadelphia area still i
live here so this is the team that i
follow that but most of my conversations
with my friends and
people around here are about the sixers
and specifically usually
about ben simmons i've kind of given up
on that thought that ak's going to add
this it's just not gonna happen this is
what he is
and we're always gonna view him as a guy
as a result
that's lacking this one skill that a
perimeter player needs in the nba now
which is the ability to beat you from
anywhere on the floor but you can't get
to superstar status
in today's game unless you have that so
i think that's a very valid point
about magic the one thing about magic i
will say i think
he's the type of guy that could probably
add it adapt to it a little bit better
than ben simmons certainly has been
willing to even compromise at all i mean
he's actually regressed
in terms of his willingness to look at
that shot from 15 feet much less the
three-point line
could you help lonzo ball i'm not saying
fix
could you help ben simmons maybe not fix
no question in my mind you know and i
know that these guys
they've spent money the teams have spent
money all these guys now have shooting
coaches they work out with in the summer
there's no question i've done it i've
not done it with a with a guy at that
level in the nba
but i've done it with countless players
and it's
it's a process that you go through and i
think there is just if you can get a guy
to focus
on two or three things and i think
there's about maybe literally
10 to 12 things that i could talk about
ad nauseam
what goes into it the mechanics of it
but you can't overwhelm a guy because
what's going to happen if you give
someone too much
they're going to end up not having
success early and they're going to go
right back to their old habits because
that's where they're comfortable
so you've got to break it down to two or
three things and each guy is different
it might be something different with
that particular player
and i do think there's there's a way to
break through that barrier mentally
and get them to buy into two or three
things from a mechanics standpoint
and help guys i don't think there's any
question about it i can sit look it's
the one thing
i've been good at in my life is doing
that and i know how to teach it i know
how to communicate it in a way that
maybe they've never heard before
so yeah i'm confident that i could do
something like that and i was always
taught
that you start about three feet out from
the basket just underneath and get your
form
and then back up make you know 10 in a
row make 10 in a row 10 and row 10 in a
row
get to the free throw line make 10 in a
row
and then you get to the top of the key
and and and that's the progression just
get your form
get the feel get the release and then
you can kind of build up your confidence
but you know you watch lonzo ball
he runs away from shooting free throws
at the end of a game
he's got a wide open three how did he
get to that point in his career
well i will give him credit because when
he came into the league
i had never seen any player shoot a
basketball the way that he did
a right-handed player releasing the ball
from his left eye socket
i had never seen anything like it and as
a result he's a guy with great vision
he's a good defender so he has all these
skills that help you win
but that was a big problem and i said
well there's no way he can ever shoot a
mid-range shot
how can you shoot a shot going to your
right your strong hand have to stop and
bring the ball back
to the area where the defender is
chasing you from can't happen and as a
result he never really takes a mid-range
shot now i will give him credit
his his stroke and release it's night
and day for when he came into the league
he's now at least a viable three-point
shooter he's a threat from out there and
you play
against with zion and brandon ingram
you're gonna have to do it he's at it i
give him a lot of credit he put the work
in
very few guys that have had that much
success to that point in their life
would be willing to put the time in and
i think that's where ben simmons i think
you can absolutely critique him
that's not important enough to him um so
i will give lonzo ball credit that he's
gotten it to that point
how he ever got a stroke that looked
like that in the first place
that's that's beyond me i i don't know
how anybody along the way didn't stop
that at a very young age and say wait a
second
what is this you're the only person on
earth who's ever shot a basketball that
way
but kevin durant does start on the left
side and brings it
over now it's different it's not as
pronounced
it's not like a windshield wiper with
lonzo ball but
you know durant i always tell people
that you know like a golf swing
don't look at everything until the point
of impact
right like where are you with club and
the ball
and it's the same thing when you shoot
however you get there
what does it look like when you end up
releasing the shot
and that's a great point and durant ends
up in perfect position he may not start
but he
ends up in a perfect position he
absolutely does and you're right and
guys are going to get it there
differently and also i will say to some
to younger players
neces those aren't necessarily the guys
you want to emulate like like for
instance
dirk nowitzki's one of the greatest
shooters in nba history
i would never advise a player that i was
working with
to shoot the ball with a 24 foot arc
i mean the distance that dirk nowitzki's
ball travels from his fingertip to the
rim maybe the greatest of any player in
history that was a good shooter
that means there's there's far less
margin for error
because of the distance it's traveling
but he's a freak
kevin durant is a freak so what you want
to what i want to try to do with guys is
look regardless of what feels
comfortable to you how you're getting it
up there
bottom line is by the time you get to
just before release
it should look the same with everybody
if you are going to be a really good
shooter i think one of the things that
i've noticed
with players uh they have a really
difficult time
getting the ball to transfer from you
know their entire hand
to their fingertips before the release
and that's a big problem that guys just
never seem to be able to break through
they also have a hard time dance
having their wrist and elbow lock at
exactly the same time
some guys never get to full extension
like zion williamson will be a great
example of that
uh and he can make an occasional three
can you imagine if he ever felt
comfortable taking that shot with the
amount of distance that people have to
give him because he's so explosive
i don't know he's gonna get there
because he doesn't extend his left arm
ben simmons is the same way
his wrist never makes it to this
position so
there are little things and look part of
it is the player how much
repetition are you willing to put into
this
he's tim legler espn nba analyst yeah uh
i don't know if you knew this but we had
ray allen in the
studio this was uh i don't know a couple
of years ago
and ray had the ball on the palm of his
hand he was just holding it and i
corrected him
i said ray and and his
look i don't know why i did it tim but i
did
here's here's maybe the greatest shooter
one of the greatest shooters
i mean it's like critiquing warren
buffett on investment
portfolio and i said i said ray you got
the ball on your palm of your hand
and i was always taught you don't have
the ball in the palm of your hand was i
wrong to critique ray allen
uh uh no no in the context that that
would be a great segment
that's that's hilarious but a guy like
that like for me he was the greatest
shooter
that i had ever seen for probably about
a decade until steph curry came along
steph curry's taken the art of shooting
to a level
i'm not sure will ever be replicated
honestly he's a once-in-a-lifetime
player he's and he's you know i do i do
think this dan i do think there's a
generation of players that steph curry
has helped and i know
the concept of the game maybe and
philosophically offensively it's hurt
some levels and some teams and some
players it's also helped guys because
there's a whole lot of kids out there
that looked at a guy that's six foot
four slightly built
not a lot of muscle definition and he
simply made himself this good
through skill repetition because i think
steph curry
might be the greatest combination of the
three skill elements of the game
past dribble shoot that we've ever seen
i think he
is the highest combination of those
three things and it was
simply done through repetition and you
don't
he didn't have to be a physical freak to
do it so i think that gives some kids
actual hope and it makes them go work on
their game a little bit harder which is
a good thing
are you all in on the jazz as far as
being an nba title contender
100 this is this is not something that's
a great story or a great start
um i i've i'm watching them deep dive
every night
again last night perfect example here's
what they do differently
than anybody else and i do compare them
to the warriors a little bit
uh when it when we first that splashed
on the scene we'd never really seen
that kind of ball movement player
movement quick decisive reads and
actions
and then ending up in the hands of a
great shooter now they don't have steph
and
clay on their team but they've got a
stable of guys that can do it
but the mentality is exactly the same
everything is quick and decisive
it's all based off a high ball screen a
dive by gobera favors
and now we're just going to get you to
react to that because if you know
they're going to score at the rim
and now we've got super high iq players
the ball is going to start hopping
around a perimeter we're always going to
make the extra pass
and you're not going to catch up to the
basketball and it's a beautiful thing to
watch because for me
that's what great offense looks like i
know we were talking about the
three-point shot and the heavy reliance
on it well when you get looks that good
yeah you should play that way
because they're making 18 of these
things at night and you think about the
warriors dan when when steph first
splashed on the scene we thought that
was the greatest shooting
team we'd ever seen they were making 13
at night
this team is making 18 a game that's how
different
this is so yes and the other thing is
they defend this isn't a one-trick pony
where they've got to outscore you they
will defend on nights where they're not
shooting well
and i think they're legit title
contender absolutely would not be
shocked
to see them say beat the clippers in the
second round
if it ends up that way and end up with
the lakers in the conference final okay
talk uh laker fans off the ledge well
look here's the thing
you have obviously you're missing a d
and shredder that's that's enormous but
here's the other thing
they're a defending champion go back
through history
defending champions you get to
mid-season there's
typically going to be a foot off the gas
a little bit mentality because the
the freshness of the season is in your
rear view mirror and they were tired
because they had a short turnaround
but the adrenaline of a new year gets
you going that's gone the playoffs are
too far away
it's cold as hell anywhere you go right
now to play
that's a downer the skies are gray
you're in a rut
you're also short-handed it's it's the
perfect time
mentally for them to sort of be going
through the motions a little bit
and that's what i see in this team there
is absolutely nothing to worry about
as long as anthony davis comes back
healthy
and stays back healthy this team is
going to the nba finals
utah might have something to say about
that so i'm not as definitive on that as
i was before the year i made a joke when
they added harold schroeder
let's just make it a 10-game season and
play to play the finals because nobody
can beat that team i don't feel as
definitive about that now because of the
jazz particularly
but still if you've got a d and you've
got that kind of versatility with lebron
and ada they're so unique
in the problems they cause for you on
both ends uh
for me it's still the lakers so nothing
to worry about
it's typical mid-season doldrums for a
defending champion
that's short-handed leg's great to catch
up with you again we appreciate your
time as always
always great dan talk soon that's tim
legler from the mothership